I advocate a revival of forgetting and
there's a number of ways to do that one
is expiration dates expiration dates
would be very simple to implement it's
just another form of metadata much like
you have file names date of creation
date of modification exact location of a
file on your hard disk and so forth and
expiration dates would just add another
category of metadata to the file system
we would be able to select the
expiration date in any form or shape we
want and be able to change it after the
fact of course but once the expiration
date has been hit the file would be
deleted by the system the importance is
that by entering or having to enter an
expiration date whenever we store
something we are reminded we are
reminded of the importance that
information is not timeless but it is
connected to a particular context in
time a and loses its value over time
most information does and so by setting
the expiration date we really link time
with information something that
biologically we cannot do if I may I'd
like to interject something here and
that is we started off and I said
there's two kind of dimensions the power
dimension that I mentioned there's a
second dimension that gets overlooked
quite frequently which I call the time
dimension and that has to do with the
fact that we humans are biologically
programmed to forget and we forget most
of what we experience every day that's a
way by which we can abstract and
generalize and evolve and grow and rid
ourselves of stuff that is no longer
relevant to us what is interesting is
there if we can't do that then we become
burdened by the details of our past to
the point that it makes us indecisive
and it shapes the way we decide we know
a little bit about that
because there is a small number of
people who cannot forget they have a
biological difficulty or forgetting so
if you ask them about a day 30 years ago
they can tell you when they got up who
called what was on television in the
morning what they had for breakfast and
so forth for every single day the last
30 years and it would be great I thought
because they would never forget where
they parked their car and the mall
parking lot but the problem is they hate
that and many of those people who have
difficulties forgetting and hate the
ability to not get rid of the old they
remember all of the mistaking decisions
or if they're past all the time and that
troubles them a great deal and it
inhibits their ability to decide and act
in the present and to think into the
future and so comprehensive digital
memory might actually create that for us
it might give us a sense of not
forgetting anymore and thereby
preventing us humans from generalizing
abstracting evolving growing and also
accepting others to change over time to
evolve them to grow and without
forgetting we don't have an ability to
forgive
I believe that the expiration date is a
way by which we humans we individuals
have a chance to reflect and to choose
so it's us that decides it's not
government it's not the processors the
online services that decide how long
they want to keep information it's us
and whenever we share information we
also add an expiration date to it and
then the other side can choose whether
to accept the information with the
expiration date or not whether to
actually cut the deal transact or not in
fact many vendors particularly online
vendors who have a very close
relationship with their customers US
consumers actually would probably prefer
or enjoy expiration dates think of
amazon com amazon now has a lot of
transactional information about my books
and other purchases that i did in the
past but what is it good for Amazon to
know what I shopped for nine months ago
or 12 months ago or 15 months ago if I'm
not longer interested in what I shopped
in it would be great for Amazon to know
not what my preferences were 15 months
ago but what my preferences are today
and with the expiration did we help the
vendors as well to limit the amount of
data that they have that is irrelevant
and to focus more on the still relevant
information to still relevant
preferences and values that they can
then use to make recommendations to us
you know the bottom line is that for all
of human history we forgot most of what
we experienced and we remembered only
those things that we thought were really
important sometimes we were right and we
remembered the right things sometimes we
were wrong and remember idiotic things
the the importance is that the
remembering was the exception in
forgetting was the default the rule and
today this has become reversed
remembering today is the default in all
of our digital tools and artifacts we
use and and forgetting deleting is
costly and time-consuming the
fundamental problem is that I want to
write this shift again and to bring back
our forgetting into our society but I
also appreciate and value the fact that
for certain kinds of information we need
to be protective we need to protect the
information keep it recorded and
archived it public information
governmental information court records
information and that the media publishes
these are all incredibly important
sources of societal memory and societal
history that we ought to preserve but
these are the exceptions the rules still
should be for most of us that we still
can forget and ought to
I don't know I don't know my sense is
that at this point in time if you have a
present convenience and a danger that is
far into the future a lot of people up
for the present convenience and so I
don't think that a lot of people today
would choose to be careful and accept of
course if they're been burned and many
many people are already suffering from
what they said on facebook or what they
tweeted and more will suffer the fact
that Twitter tweets are now archived and
recorded in the library of congress
brings that point to the to the
forefront the fact is that twitter for a
very long period of time has let other
companies look at the twitter feeds it's
not just the Library of Congress that
has it its many other commercial
companies that have twitter feeds and
they're actually doing stuff with it and
that might come to haunt us the more
people are getting affected by it the
more will change the behavior I am
troubled by the fact that many will many
of those people will change their
behavior toward with self censorship and
I I'm troubled by it because that's not
what we need in a society and that is
denying the the web tools that we have
today the value that is inherent in them
in sharing knowledge and experiences and
so forth